were trapped on the 38th floor and the
telephone system below - amazingly
enough Tom Hanks at his fingertips on
the cutting edge of technology in the
1998 movie you got male but his real
passion lies in typewriters CBS Sunday
mornings Lee cow and spoke with the
Academy Award winner about how a love of
old typewriters inspired Hanks to write
his first book uncommon type look at
that isn't it then a fine manly manly
taste when Tom Hanks who collects old
typewriters as a hobby suggested that I
might be a little cooler if I owned one
- Who am I to say no if you wanted the
perfect typewriter that would last
forever that would be a great
conversation piece mmm I'd say get the
smooth karana clipper that will be as
satisfying a typing experience as you
will ever have
I was sold that Corona clipper now sits
in my office but I'm looking at this and
I have to say got it got it got it
Hank's himself owns more than a hundred
vintage typewriters and he knows as much
about them as the good folks here at
Gramercy typewriter in New York City
this is the typewriter that got man to
the moon it redefined what a what a
typewriter was he's even created a
typewriter app he calls it Hanks writer
it's as quaint as it is fun but it
certainly takes some skill there is
perhaps no greater evidence of Hanks
love of typewriters then the fact he
named his book after them uncommon type
a collection of seventeen short stories
his first attempt at moving from actor
to author scared no
there's no romantic meeting at the top
of the Empire State Building but he does
write some lovely tales about romance
and heartache nonetheless there's no boy
trapped in a man's body but there is a
story about a boy and a sports car this
is from a special weekend and the
driveway was an actual sports car red a
two-seater with wire wheels the wood
paneling was like furniture the seats
smelled like leather baseball mitts the
red circle in the middle of the steering
wheel said Fiat that's right
fiat Hanks has always loved the promise
of the future he's too young to have
attended the 1939 World's Fair but he
wishes he couldn't there was such a huge
great faith in man's capabilities of
improving the world and I just thought
that's right down my alley man so he
wrote about a man who time traveled his
way back there
thanks to money earned off inventing a
gadget that only Hanks could imagine was
that one a fun one to write because this
yeah yeah that was it just the words you
get to use the invention I got I have to
read it next I will never ever do the
shuffle access digital valve relay yeah
that's an invention yeah but you know
there's probably a couple in the cameras
right now I consider rounded come up
with names like that all the time that's
that's that's a dense dense solid solid
machine in case you're wondering no he
didn't write his book on a typewriter
but he's woven a typewriter in every
story an easter egg as he calls it for
the reader to find it helped me
formulate oddly enough it formulate each
each story there really yeah there was
his each paper had sort of a personality
to it yeah yeah exactly I have three or
four of this actual Olympia do you
really yeah because let me look how
beautiful it is right he says he still
uses one of his many typewriters almost
every day even if it's just for a
grocery list they are not only a
touchstone to the past he says but and
invitation to sit down at the keys and
let his mind and his fingers watch if I
see enough stories at around and start
asking enough questions about where it
would go to yeah I hope to write more we
hope so too
there you go kid CBS this morning we
counted New York and all the caution 973
my wrong
that's terrific I was intrigued about
what people collect yeah what do you
collect Charlie nothing particular okay
stories the questions great interviews
exactly great interviews I mean I
haven't read the Tom Hanks book yet I'm
looking forward to I mean I yeah that
was a great that was a great intriguing
yes